so how's your head what's going through
your head today after taping the finale
you know it's done you know I I tried to
through this whole week actually number
of months now really appreciate and let
the process happen emotionally and
checked every box and thank everybody
top to bottom and and pry every tear
when they came up honestly and so I feel
really I feel great I feel nothing but
absolute gratefulness if we're talking
tissues
how many do what's the count
well I'm not the classiest guy so we'd
have to count sleeves more than more
than tissues even when crying I'm a
little punk rock you know we've been
talking so much about like how you guys
the trajector trajectory of you all over
the 12 years what do you wear do you
kind of put your life before and now at
Big Bang you know how what was your
lifestyle like before and opposed to now
Wow it's changed drastically I mean I
don't a lot of people don't know that my
career you know has not been seamless
you know immediately before Big Bang I
was in Wisconsin studying plumbing it
sounds crazy I wanted to open a design
studio for bathrooms and spas so I had
to learn the plumbing on it so there's
there's been a lot of peaks and valleys
and I'm I feel very fortunate I'm
grateful for all of them so from where
my life was six months before the show
and where we are now is vastly did it's
changed my life it's changed my family's
life I couldn't be more more grateful I
do have to ask because I'm over using
that word
you cannot say gratitude enough there's
a lot of weight and meaning in that word
and it's appropriate in any connotation
that you lose it and definitely um if
Chuck came to you six months down the
line and said I still feel like I have
Penny and Leonard stories to tell or
linen stories so would you ever consider
a spinoff would you don't think so I
think I think I think these friends they
share seven different areas of the of
one brain in a way and I don't think I
don't think any anyway you split them up
with would work necessarily I mean it
might work it might work for a little
more
it might work well but I think we need
to kind of let what was built here built
you know kind of breathe and get through
everyone's blood streams before that's
even considered I can't imagine did you
take the gum wall at the end of the film
the gum wall because I was told that
your chewed up gum is the one that
decorates that was what kind of the
common theme is here yeah yeah that kept
that wall together that's it that's
that's the that's the carpenter name
[Music]
[Applause]